6 25 on your wednesday morning well not
beethoven or mozart but clark county may
have just composed a tune that you could
call
variations on a speed bump i think we're
all familiar with speed bumps but did
you catch this on the news the other day
county commissioner tick sega bloom
talking about the speed bump variation
they've introduced called the speed
cushion now this is on spencer in the
near southeast valley
the reality is we need to stop
in these older neighborhoods
particularly people cutting through
in this case between flamingo and desert
inn so we're trying to figure out a way
to slow traffic down we now have these
new speed cushions which are not cement
they're they're rubbers they even sent
us video
of the speed cushion
in action
hang on
[Music]
uh-huh
right up there with watching paint dry
that's the speed cushion try to calm
yourself
well the county is calling these speed
cushions a pilot project to see what the
actual impacts are to traffic and the
neighborhood call it whatever you want
if it gets you to slow down i'm all for
it buckle help drive carefully please
put on that phone if there is something
driving you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com